I am Jesus I am Joseph we're going to
watch the trailer for kung fury kung
fury yeah apparently it's this like film
that they're trying to get made and like
they put a trailer together I think like
a sizzle reel you know to try to raise
money for it I hope this is the story
that's what I think yeah so yeah yeah
anyway everyone's been telling me to
watch this trailer like literally
everywhere I go every um yeah every
loose stuff oh I don't know we're coming
up to me checker at rouses like you
watch that kung fu [ __ ]
yeah man he made me feel like [ __ ] yeah
what about my Reese's peanut butter cups
and everything one okay cuz Reese's
Peanut Butter Cup solve everything they
do so they really do let's get her a
come on ha does that sound nope sounds
like another word yeah hey that one
ain't seen one imagine a character who's
like a crazy woman she's called [ __ ]
fury we're gonna watch the trailer hey
you got a permit for those guns
I've got your permit right here
this one looks badass oh come - he's a
gun foo renegade cop I don't want to
hear it come fury I just paid a city
hall you just destroyed an entire city
block for Christ's sake
I quit now we must defeat the most evil
come from master in the world Adolf
Hitler it gets yeah yeah
it's the worst criminal ball time did
you kill it oh boy hacking back in time
Nazi German just like a time machine
oh it's really it's so cool I want I
want this to get I want us to get made
too much in time I went too far back in
time oh this is too goddamn bike aah
[ __ ] Metal Gear Solid from the future I
need your help
whoa
unspeakable adventures never before
shown in a motion picture
get ready bar comfier e that looks
pretty awesome it does look pretty dude
that film I've seen a lot of trailers
recently that I am jacked up but yeah I
gotta get every money to that film that
looks like so much I would love to
contribute money to that yeah because
that looks like one hell of a good time
serious like the things like everything
you want it's so cheesy and it's like
awesome at the same time it is a
nostalgia but like only in only the way
somebody who's nostalgic for the 80s
could do it yeah it seems like it's so
over the top and it's like a video game
it's do stuff though the 80s hasn't done
yes I like just doing a rehash of the
80s like they're like taking it to a
whole video game level yes I love it
there's only somebody who loves the 80s
but today could yeah well yeah yeah
great way to put it yeah like it looks
like a blast and yeah I'm going to pay
money to them yeah no money right now in
fact this is turning into an
advertisement go give them as money of
them some [ __ ] money right now if
you're watching this that you better
give them it and like our like the video
and fam subscribe us subscribe good way
and I have more videos of me reacting to
it
of you watching stuff of me watching
stuff